I was gonna say dude so much as having
this last week you thought about nerd
cities video dude that [ __ ] was [ __ ]
great amazing his videos are awesome he
does so much care yeah and effort into
those videos a lot of thought yeah
a lot of thought and long and research
and everything also I don't know my only
my only complaint about that so heat so
if you don't know he posted a video
about YouTube monetization stuff which I
guess might interest you a mine on I
don't know I feel like if you watched
videos on YouTube you're just inherently
interested in in everything that has to
do with YouTube right I don't know maybe
I wouldn't say that maybe not I used to
hate it when people talked about [ __ ]
money on YouTube yeah as a guys reviewer
house I just want to watch the videos I
guess if you could frame it in a way
that is um not sort of for it I don't
know if you don't give a [ __ ] let me
frame it this way there have been a
long-standing theory that YouTube was
trying to sort of suppress and basically
yeah like negatively affect LGBT q yeah
content yeah and a lot of those creators
were saying for a while like my videos
get demonetised the second I talk about
anything related to my community and
it's [ __ ] [ __ ] and some creators
had the opportunity to question people
at YouTube and people YouTube would say
really sort of like you know lawyer [ __ ]
like well there's no policy that ya got
no list of words yeah and so no there's
like as soon as you put gay in the title
yeah it would get D monetized instantly
and lesbian and I mean so whatever I
mean you can dive deep into the bit like
the exact words through nerd cities
video but nerd City featured I forget
the guys name I feel like a dick
basically this guy started a patreon
where he keeps an active list of words
that are will get you D monetized and
haman like another team of guys have
basically figured out that it's like a
spectrum so like a collection of words
can tip the scale to get the video
demonetised right it's like you know and
some of those words are pretty and
oculus as it got me thinking though
about why like I linked one like
destroyed is a word but I then I started
thinking about it
it's probably for more like those
techrax type channels and stuff like I
phone gets destroyed by lava or whatever
yeah but why are those not monetizable
that I mean that's the part that's like
what the [ __ ] like they don't explain
why any of those words have negative
weight the big the biggest thing is that
once it gets to monetized well no
actually not the biggest thing but it's
you know for people that are trying to
make a living that that really matters
but then also nobody sees the video yeah
they just don't [ __ ] recommend it as
much and it doesn't it doesn't get
shared as much on YouTube so like the
views will always end up being way lower
and it's like it's just and then like
the the biggest thing is that is that
your no idea why mm-hmm but thing but
the thing my issue with the whole thing
is that I don't feel like I don't feel
like they figured it out like the list
of words and stuff like that I really
feel like there's almost with this
algorithm that's learning right it's
like a it's like a language processing
thing that like teach itself
yes itself or like a machine learning
algorithm yeah it's like teaching itself
what's monetizable and D monetizable as
time goes on yeah
that adds like an element of like
randomness to it yeah like I [ __ ]
this latest cringe the first version I
uploaded to get approved for the brain
read or whatever yeah what's fine sat
there for two days was monetized and
then I uploaded a version that was like
literally I just all I just took [ __ ]
out that's all I did
uploaded it got do you monetize right
away I deleted it I boarded the same
copy was fine
no words nothing added so then what the
[ __ ] is happens there's what is it
seeing there's that and like I've had
steamy tweets literally every Sistema
tweets video gets ramana ties that is
really interesting I've asked you in
like your write a video Ramanna ties and
you're like no never
well sometimes it'll show yellow like as
a bug and you'll be like oh it's
demonetised and you'll look back in two
hours and it's gone no I've had it like
it goes up it's yellow I submit a
request stays yellow some days later the
engagement is really high it [ __ ] it
goes green
I swear on on God does he have this is
this is so like it's so [ __ ]
frustrating how like random it is mmm
now every edge of this awful feeling of
my gut when I spent 10 hours on a video
and I upload it and I'm just like
praying to God I don't see that yellow
symbol yeah and I keep refreshing videos
and then it shows up and I'm like yep
God cuz that's like three more hours I'm
gonna have to spend mmm
[ __ ] re uploading it and figuring out
what the [ __ ] is the issue yes like it's
such a pain in the [ __ ] ass yeah well
I'm hate to complain about it but god it
matters so much you know in our like
it's just such an awful feeling it I
mean is happening to our podcast YouTube
every time every single episode we
upload on on our podcast channel gets T
monetized yeah so now like you can see
like the views are tapering and it's
like obviously because it's just not
getting recommended like no one sees it
I mean I see comments being like I
didn't even know this was posted yeah
which is which is wild you know it's
wild I mean well so I think to to punch
it all and the thing I find I was
actually reading today some like Twitter
thread which goes hand-in-hand with nerd
city's video is what he was pointing out
is YouTube is not they're not a
progressive company because they want to
be big everywhere you know in big
countries where you know being gays
illegal yeah you know or it's very
culturally very not acceptable you know
and so the truth of it is is that they
want content that skews to broader
values so that they can you know be big
everywhere because they're a global
brand yeah but which I don't know if you
can prove but I'm also not sure if
that's that valid because they also like
target advertising like they have
American advertising that is targeted to
American people that's on American
content that's only you know I'm saying
yeah
but I I I agree in that like I do think
they're using like a fix-all situation
where it's like collectively we'll just
we'll just kind of just the gay stuff
because like they don't want to have to
I don't know yeah like I guess tailor
the algorithm yeah different or by
region I'm sure that gets very
complicated really quickly not really
cuz their whole system is based on yeah
I mean I guess yeah region yeah yeah if
you yeah because if you're just flagging
by like I mean even if you use like a
simple flag like in the [ __ ] URL like
by language or yeah or domain then yeah
you in theory you should be able to I
don't know make changes yeah maybe not
but I like I'm yeah yes are cubic oh no
I just I think that more than there are
people who are forward-thinking there
are people who are not and I think that
that's what they cater to yeah and I
mother what the [ __ ] the thread was
about but it was like kind of commenting
on how like like specifically you know
when when corporations and stuff put out
videos being like we accept all kinds of
people's like they're full of [ __ ]
yeah they don't they oh yeah it was it
was South Park making fun of Disney yeah
saying that they tailors making fun of
Disney I want they tailor their videos
to China and how they they are they
cater because they want to be massive in
China as well so they will cater to
whatever prejudices that are that exist
yeah and in China and and people were
quoting sort of like complaints about
the black panther which were just
ridiculous
yeah it was like ridiculous complaints
and so yeah i don't know i guess i guess
maybe maybe that's i did I felt like a
lot of the stuff in that video where
we're like pretty like sweeping
hypotheses yeah that didn't have a lot
of actual stuff to back it up but like I
yeah I mean yeah I think in I think at
the end of the day I do think that they
do have a list where they are keeping
tabs on what does and does not work yeah
I think dads for sure yeah and why they
do it you could argue that all day but I
just think you know what the
people at that trade union so basically
in the video guys there this guy Joerg
Sprave do you know who he is
now dude I remember watching his videos
like way back he had like a slingshot
channel he build these crazy slingshots
ya say hmm I started getting D monetized
because I guess it was like they looked
at it as like him advising how to build
weapons okay cuz he was building some
pretty crazy [ __ ] whatever he is like
working with some like European like
Workers Union that's been around for
like a hundred years and they're trying
to basically get like youtubers like or
people who create content for YouTube
like as part of this Union and I think
what they are saying is the most
interesting it's like just make it clear
stop making everyone guess yeah like be
definitive about what the [ __ ] issue
yeah
well they say it they they say that they
do that so that they don't have any bad
actors mm-hmm trying to game the system
yeah but it's like everyone's [ __ ]
trying to figure it out anyways bro why
do you think this [ __ ] is happening why
do you think this guy is a patreon for
researching words that get him on it
like just you can avoid all of this [ __ ]
just [ __ ] tell us what it is yeah
yeah cuz like kids channels aren't
gaming the system yeah exactly yeah you
know Jake Paul never games this is no
not at all yeah it's not like he was
advertising to children for [ __ ] five
years yeah yeah Logan Paul didn't game
the system at all you know every single
J station didn't get [ __ ] game you
know I'm saying like every one games
this is you that's the [ __ ] problem
yeah it's like you know they and and
even they're a whole [ __ ] theory
about like Oh putting like a title for
something that you know isn't the actual
content that then just [ __ ] thumbs
down and if the thumbs down exceed the
thumbs up then punish the video in some
way you know like there's I just don't I
don't know yeah I think it was
interesting regardless no it was a great
video nerd cities their cities videos
are always [ __ ] great it just felt to
me like it was just scratching the
surface of what oh yeah [ __ ] the system
is what is happening I think that's what
I mostly mean it just felt like we were
kind of like well it could be this it
could be because they're catering to
people who think homosexuality should be
illegal and all this [ __ ] and it's like
it could just
[ __ ] machine learning algorithm that
that some dudes that are working at
YouTube demonetized a few videos of
coming out videos or whatever for
whatever reason and then the system
learned that okay this is the type of
video that gets you monetize so yes goes
forward yeah and that's what it does
which is [ __ ] up but who it could be
that it could be something else you know
yeah who knows how didn't nerd City open
the video he was like like it starts and
he's like gay alright now that it's
demonetised
love that yeah that's what the that's
why our [ __ ] gets to monetize the
unconvincing gay dude yeah what the [ __ ]
do you mean I'm [ __ ] gay dude I want
to highlight a few from the list that
we're so funny okay yeah all right boobs
with three o's do it no you can't do it
with four we should name this episode of
boobs can't do it with five okay and you
can't do it with six
what about seven what about seven one
two three oh my god this is so you ever
like looked at it's so hard looking at
zeros without commas yeah this is seven
of flex yeah yeah in in boobs you need
commas in boobs
no I'm saying was that a flex know it's
so hard looking at zeros without commas
in between I'm joking okay anything like
[ __ ] that many zeros get that either
no actually this has tested for five OS
and seven but not six okay so we should
test we should name this episode booze
with six out of six oh yeah um [ __ ] and
[ __ ] liquor no go really [ __ ] liquor got
to monetize yeah Wow
well I mean it is surprising considering
that [ __ ] face and [ __ ] [ __ ] are fine
clitoris with an eye is demonetized but
clitoris the the UK version is okay
clitoris clitoris clitoris clitoris
um essential payer had to click race
y'all hate
my [ __ ] hands what about [ __ ] wrists
klitz is not cool but clitty and clitty
litter
Liddy litter ooh why did they come up
how do they come up with these to test
them I don't know
they're like he uses like an API testing
some dirty word yeah API yeah
dirty that's so funny daddy someone had
to make that it's a dirty API you'll
clitty litter I like that that's sick
what's glitty litter Linton pubic hair
random random pubic hair while eating
your girl's box Oh how's that clitty
litter oh sorry a little clean litter
I loved the [ __ ] the list on oncome
related I was very surprised we're gonna
go through this we're doing this so if
you're at the office turn this part all
the way up put it up come is not it's
not cool it's got a asterisk next to it
um come chugger works really yeah but
cumdumpster isn't no that's Steve will
do its next video come dumster come
chugger come sugar yeah chugging -
leaders have come most come chugged in
one time and this is him with a weak
smile and a bunch of come in a big old
cup alright um alright alright I'm gonna
check this come no one's Chuck this much
come before guys I'm a chugging our
audio just gets passed through the
YouTube algorithm and she's like oh oh
what if that the core of it they just
blame us they throw us under the bus
well we get podcast like the tiny meat
gang yeah and it makes it very hard to
figure out what's monetize them they're
actually the whole reason why this
system exists is because of the tiny
meat gang podcast the whole reason none
of you are making any money
come bubble come freak and come dump all
good
come guzzler come jockey comer just come
her he's a comer he's a comer yeah
coming a guy a guy [ __ ] a lot he's a
comer the big ol comer come come in with
no G a ok coming with the G
no good ah Cummings all right see the
English language is so Cu mmm ing yeah
SS name yeah Bert Cummings yeah my name
is James Cummings it's nice to meet you
I am a comer
my name is Ivana come in Lima cut if
you're part of that family
yeah I'm a-coming Yamma Cummings James
coming nice to meet you I'm also a
coming you know he's a coming I'm coming
[Laughter]
I'm coming
um this list is almost done guys don't
worry if comes [ __ ] come shots no
good
sorry sorry dude perfect Yoda with my
boys we're doing doing 20 foot [ __ ] shot
off a stadium balcony
that's so good yeah my boys mouth is
down there I'm gonna ten stories down
and I'm gonna nut right in his mouth
over my shoulder
we're just watching it fall Kyle down
there here's the best did come tart no
space all good what does cumulative mean
cumulative cumulative that's the only
one where it's pronounced cume huh
almost started say I'm gonna cume I'm
cubing I'm cubing I'm gonna Kim I'm I'm
gonna keep a last one kind of Lingus
with one L is not okay but two L's DC
and honey ie is good okay good
let's you're come honey okay Connie hey
Connie hey Connie
yo David just want to say good night and
you're my little honey all right have a
good one from Noel see ya love Cody
mmm ah that's from Cody yeah
me oh my god what
I'd even noticed the bottom of this list
it's um it's the c-word calmed [ __ ] [ __ ]
jumped yeah it comes holy [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] ass and [ __ ] [ __ ] are
monetizable come back see if it works
boobs and cut bags I'm eight I'm [ __ ]
eight years old dude
[Music]